the
new england patriots still alive even
though plenty of people in the boston
media were throwing dirt on the dynasty
isn't it weird chris that nationally
there was a sense that the patriots
would find a way to get it done but if
anything it was the local media the
local fan base that that doubted the
patriots yeah i mean hands down i go up
on the new england you know regional
sports network for nbc on a weekly basis
and found them to be the most negative
on the patriots consistently through the
month of december uh and to the point
where they weren't going to ask me who
won the game last week or who's going to
win the game right they were like
already chalking up like we think you're
going to say the chiefs just like
everybody else and i was like no i mean
you got a real chance here this is the
new england patriots and once again they
took away all the strengths of one team
and you know of course had this
masterful game plan and that's why
they're in their ninth super bowl
and uh
uh i think it's the emotional hedge i
think that's what the folks in boston
were doing and look there was reason for
it sure they they had that ugly loss in
miami then they went to pittsburgh where
they they typically have some sort of a
weird mastery over the steelers and the
steelers beat them and it just felt like
it was all falling apart and tom brady
looked mortal and it looked like father
time was finally catching up to him and
gronk had disappeared i mean gronk had a
stretch of four games where he did
nothing before yesterday at least in the
passing game he'd been blocking well but
as a pass catcher he hadn't contributed
much of anything he had one game with no
catches along the way but uh yeah doubt
them long enough and they're going to
come back and they're going to get you
so maybe all that maybe all that was
useful maybe the patriots believed that
there was this national sense that they
stink because that's all they were
hearing locally and if that was the
objective it worked well yeah certainly
i mean they're gonna find anything and
hey gronk edelman brady are they as good
as they were four or five years ago no
they're not but we're still we still saw
that they're very capable of delivering
in big moments and still really good
weapons to have on the football field
but more importantly the new england
patriots have realized those players are
not the same that they used to be and
that's why they become a running
football team and drafting o-line in the
first and second round and sony michelle
down your throat all game long we're
going to talk about brady in the past
game a lot but they ran the ball for 170
something yards once again and that's
really the beauty of belichick and brady
and they always find the right formula
and that that chief's front seven that
pierced the great blue wall
last weekend and it had no luck against
the red white red white and blue wall
that the patriots have that's right
that's all i'm going to say about that
patriotism
no sex by the chiefs uh and very few
hits on tom brady and if you're going to
be brady you got to hit him early and
you got to get pressure up the middle oh
by the way the rams may be able to do
that and finally
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports